I recently invested 20 months ago in a
piece of real estate I got it for
385,000 it's probably worth it's Le at
least half a mill today and the problem
is I'm 25 years old my co-signer was not
a parent or a girlfriend is actually a
person that I've worked with at a
restaurant and she recently told me that
she would like her name to get off of
the loan so that she could start uh
looking for a piece of real estate for
herself and the only way for me to get
her name off is to refinance which would
double my interest rate right now so
we've got to look at some other
Solutions here one of them might be we
have to sell this place that was once a
dream has now become the nightmare we
stepped into it too soon too early with
a friend who co-signed who now wants out
of it